[Applause]
ladies and gentlemen now my next guest
tonight has been on television since
1949. she's won a total of five
emmys on shows such as the mary tyler
moore show mama's family and the golden
girls
well she's just written a new book
entitled here we go again my life
in television please welcome betty white
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
oh
[Applause]
well i know but i i hear that music and
it takes a girl back you know it really
does
well thanks very much for coming as i
said up front i've always wanted to meet
you it's very nice to have you but we've
got that done now we don't have to worry
about that anymore
it's done it's over exactly we've had
actually i'm a huge fan of the old mary
tyler moore show and we've had it we had
mary tyler moore on there just don't
call her the old mary tyler moore that's
not something
you know i know i'm sorry i'm loaded and
then of course we had ed asner on the
show
and uh off the pipe yeah here we go
good lord
excuse me my god
what won't you do just let me ask you
just indulge a fan for one second then
we'll get on to your crack humor there
i know you love to do that stuff on
shows but uh tell us on that show the
casting
so brilliant on that show everyone fit
the part just right and your character
suanne nivens
you were perfect in that part and i was
curious was that part written exactly
for you
yeah they well they wrote it for a
sickeningly sweet
icky yucky betty white type mm-hmm and
they
said betty white type white type and
they said the casting director said well
why don't you get betty and they said
well no mary and betty are friends
she can't possibly if she doesn't get
the part mary will be upset
so they tried about i guess about 12
other actresses
and they couldn't find anybody quite
sickening enough so they said well give
it to betty she can
it's true it's a true story that's very
very charming story now tell me it's
true
they so they finally brought you in they
brought me in and it was just to be a
one shot
but i was sickening enough that they
they kept the they kept you around
well uh it's me all of us are huge fans
here at the show we're very glad to have
you andy
very nice to have you here i was curious
i mentioned at the top
because i'm kind of i i love uh i'm just
into tv history and
in general you start in the 40s you've
been doing this for 1949 i've been in
for 46 years now
you must have seen things change quite a
bit are they are they drastically
different now
well they're drastically different a lot
of similarities oddly enough
but the audiences have changed i mean
the audiences now
you have to really keep them interested
because they've seen everything been
there done that
and so now you get they used to when we
were on it was also the test pattern
and we've got about no we had a rating
of about 60
would watch us and the other 40 would
watch the test pattern
that would sort of be bad for morale
well it wasn't it was not a bad test ben
now uh now tell me about i know you did
you did many game shows
in your time yeah everyone i think that
was ever extoned i'm a game nut
all right your game show now and you
sort of made it a staple of using double
entendre racy language that that was
kind of your special not racy language
and i don't ever do it on purpose well
sort of things with a double meaning
i see i have a pun kind of a mentality
and i you see a second meaning to things
so i would go through life doing that
and a lot of people never heard it at
all and they the top
level never bothered them that was fine
and the ones who did get the second
meaning
they got a kick out of it but they
didn't hurt anybody now of course
there's no such thing as dublin ton or
single anton do they just
let it all hang out what are they going
to do when they run out of body parts i
wanted to talk about
i don't know that's a dark day for tv
oh it is you mean you just think it's
gotten too explicit now is that i
shouldn't say that i just said it's
different from what we started
yeah i i got almost bleeped
on the jack par show because jack looked
at the audience one night and said betty
loves animals
so much if you uh have a dog or a cat
call betty or if you want a dog or a cat
call betty and i said don't do that
you may i'm becoming more of a procurer
every day
well not nobody would think twice about
that now
right well mercy miss lucy and they see
god
well my word did you hear the word that
betty white used on on
so they had to grow up procure and they
had to go back and look at the tape
before they'd let the show go out to
to the west coast well finally they
skinny through they said well i guess
poor betty didn't know what she was
saying
and and we'll let the thing go out
well shortly after that not too long
after that jack parr was telling a story
about
uh wc a water closet
well they really got upset then and they
bleeped him on the west coast
you couldn't even reference a bathroom
no and jack
heard about it and he mentioned it in
his monologue the next night and he got
up and walked off the show
and didn't stop and he got to hong kong
and he was there for six weeks he
wouldn't come back to the show
very famous he left and went to hong
kong and went to hong kong
those days if you did that they'd put an
infomercial in your spot it would do
just about as well and they'd leave you
in hong kong
that's what happened to me if i walked
out of here yeah oh it's sad
what's happened to tv why don't you try
to walk out see what happens
okay i'm doing it tomorrow tomorrow i'm
walking out and going to hong kong and
like six weeks later people say what
happened to that show
to work show it's a what show what
happened exactly all right now just tell
us because we're running out of time the
new show
uh is called it's with marie osmond the
osmond's called maybe this time
the book is here we go again and the
show is maybe this time here we go again
maybe this time she'll get out of the
business
osmond and betty white
[Laughter]
you'll be surprised chris rock will be a
special guest some week
done right here can chris rock be okay
he'll be a special guest and andy and i
will see marie would love it all right
well okay maybe this time it's gonna be
saturdays at 8
30. saturday is it 8 30. thank you
thank you very much for coming come on
over tomorrow we're signing books at b
dalton i'd like that betty white
everybody we'll take we'll be right back
you